[Music]
Annihilator I don't like that
name
look
pretty like sh
know
Carol danvas prodigal child of the Milky
Way Nick Fury my favorite oneeyed man of
Entry how goes it out there you know
cold no air
[Applause]
space Captain Marvel the
annihilator you took everything from
me and now I'm returning the
[Music]
favor what is happening to
me she's entangled our light based
Powers so we switch places whenever we
use them
strong Theory you can absorb
light I can see it and Camala who's
Camala hi she can turn light into
physical matter which I have never heard
of I can totally show you
[Music]
no be you
down first to St
[Music]
she's targeting every planet we call
home I would never choose to bring
anybody into this you are not the only
thing standing between this and the
universe oh my God we're a team
you
higher
further
faster
[Music]
who's that good get
go oh my
God I can't can you I got
[Music]
it